toi aussi tu vas apprendre à lire et à
écrire comme les bras Man et les
fermiers bonjour papa est parti tôt ce
matin il doit déjà être à l'atelier
salut
prends le balai qui est là
qui t'a frappé le maître on doit partir
on doit quitter ni à ma tablette partir
d'ici pour aller où maman où est-ce
qu'on va
[Musique]
papa
maman c'est papa
[Musique]
c'est ton père il a eu un accident
maître
on est couvert de dettes Tintin
qu'est-ce qu'on va devenir je suis
désolé je n'ai pas de bonne nouvelle
c'est la même chose que Grand-mère
je peux pas te en l'air
maintenant
[Musique]
tu couches avec un étranger tu me fais
honte toi qui est en train d'essayer de
me vendre au bataillon là pour éponger
les dettes de la famille et vendre ta
fille alors tu trouves pas que ça tu es
en toi
les Amazones
ces femmes de l'antiquité
formaient un peuple de guerrière crainte
et respecté
elle menait de nombreuses batailles dont
elles sortaient souvent vainqueur les
historiens se disputent sur la nature de
leur origine mais pour beaucoup les
Amazones restent en mystère
[Musique]